hey guys so this is part 2 covering
everything we learned about Dark Souls 2
at e3 click here to see the previous
video if you haven't already and use the
links in each description to sort of
navigate to different topics within this
video so at e3 there were class choices
for Dark Souls 2 just like Resort Dark
Souls at e3 2011 however traditional
character creation seems to have taken a
bit of a change as well you won't choose
the class system anymore at least from
the way I understand it but instead
you'll customize your character through
some tutorial sessions by the sounds of
things these will incorporate a variety
of questions maybe like would you prefer
to attack quickly or would you prefer to
take a lot of hits then the game selects
a class for you based on that play style
we didn't get to experience this
tutorial session so it remains to be
seen how this will work in practice it
might not even be a big deal so let's go
through the character archetypes that
were playable at e3 first up was the
sorcerer there's a few changes here
pressing l1 with the catalyst equipped
allows you to perform a faster standard
spell l2 does a slower more powerful
version of the spell close-quarters
fighting was apparently still difficult
although it looks like casters will have
a huge variety and depth to their spells
the P are in charge of one of the booths
emphasized that enhanced customization
would be possible even for the spells
you cast it looks like Fromm is trying
to make every playstyle more viable
since sorcery and bow builds felt really
tacked on and less viable in Dark Souls
1 so one interesting side note about the
sorcerer is that you see him using fire
sorcery it's not pyromancy which is done
with a pyromancy and it's sorcery which
uses a catalyst and for everyone who
follows the law as much as I do this is
a pretty big deal because fire sorcery
is apparently a lost art does this mean
that the game is a prequel set before
the fire sorcery was lost or doesn't
mean that the fire sorcery was just
rediscovered somehow impaired in mind
this is from software we're talking
about so I'm pretty sure they'll have an
explanation ready for us but what do you
think do you think this means it's a
prequel let me know another awesome
character was the dual swordsman not
just because of his glorious cloth
physics every weapon in each
seems to have a unique r1 and a unique
r2 holding triangle instead of dual hand
in your right hand weapon puts you into
sort of like a power stance from which
you can perform a unique attack parrying
doesn't seem to be an option anymore
with dual wielding at least with the
weapons he was using but at least this
means that there'll be a huge array of
combos open to anyone who actually
decides to do a wheel moving towards the
to more standard characters we have this
footage of a temple knight using a
halberd and a hand axe here you'll
notice that the chip damage from the
enemy assault seems to be much more
common it was also confirmed by the devs
that some of the shields used as
catalysts can be used as catalysts for
casting spells adding strength to the
sort of paladin archetype and the final
character we'll cover is the warrior
that we've seen so much of whose
gameplay is pretty standard the best
thing I can think of to talk over during
his footage is that you can now hold
three things in each hand so weapons
shields talismans sorcery catalysts all
that stuff three in each hand so this
offers more variety but remember that
you'll still be trying to keep your
equipment load in mind so you're not
going to overburden yourself now if
you're super observant you might have
noticed a few more changes to the core
gameplay mechanics so in terms of
movement rolling seems to have changed
in that if you have a lighter character
you actually roll faster which is
nothing new and further as well as well
as acquiring more invincibility frames
than a heavier character so the extra
invincibility frames is a cool change
although playtesters noticed that
invincibility frames were really
difficult to exploit in the demo I also
have a feeling from the gameplay that
there won't be categories like fast or
old medium roll and heavy roll anymore
from the gameplay it seems like the roll
speed and distance scales with the
character weight I could be wrong though
parrying is reportedly much the same at
this stage although one journalist
mentioned that he could knock enemies to
the ground with it perhaps that's also a
method of crowd control playtesters
mentioned that they had a really hard
time parrying which is interesting
because it's already fairly challenging
as well back stabs are where most of the
changes appear and that's good
considering back steps need a nerf in
both PvE and PvP firstly they're harder
to perform I mentioned earlier that
enemies pivot much faster and track your
much better secondly they're really
really dynamic this time around a series
of complex slashes take place with short
swords and some testers mentioned that
they picked up the enemy with their stab
and slammed him onto the ground
but now these different animations
actually matter because many play
testers were shocked to discover that
they could actually take damage while
performing the animation this is a big
change imagine what it will be like to
be broken out of that backstab animation
or to take damage during it it makes me
wonder if it's possible to cancel the
animation after delivering a few blows
bearing this in mind what you prefer to
choose a light weapon with a backstab
that does a series of slashes or a heavy
weapon that winds up towards a big
damage if you have the time to perform
the attack animations madam now and back
steps no longer seem to be the best way
to deal with groups of humanoid enemies
so I'm sure from will fix the
overpowered role they used to play
especially in PvP as well another thing
at the core of a Souls game is subtle
implicit clues Dark Souls tells its
story through item locations it tells
you where to go by prompting your
intuition and your attention to detail
can help you navigate the game world
even in the demo we got a glimpse of
this there's a fragile wall in one of
the areas that hides a shortcut and the
wall can be smashed open if you bait a
total Knight into hitting the wall or
Dodger throw an explosive at the right
moment in another interview with polygon
you return in mirror the game's director
mentioned that he was really excited
about the possibilities within the new
engine he said that the engine had more
potential for subtle expression so not
like facial expression but like the
little hints that exist within the
gameplay without giving too much away
the example he gave was representing an
off-screen enemy with the movement of
shadow I can't predict what other cool
little things they'll throw into the
game but considering that we're still
discovering new things about Dark Souls
now imagine what possibilities they'll
have within the new engine now as a
final note you remember that a few
people were worried that the character
was blocking 100% physical damage with
the torch in an earlier demo so here's
what happened when Rubicon attempted to
block the total Knights giant hammer
with the torch this time around Rubicon
was fighting the total knight and
attempted to block with the torch the
blow completely staggered his character
the total Knight then walked behind him
during the stagger animation
and smacked his back into the ground I
think they fixed it guys a link to Road
Kahn's experience with the demo can be
found in the description so getting
towards the end now but I did save a lot
of the best to last interestingly
there's a few rumors of demon souls 2
coming out of e3 not dark souls 2 demon
souls 2 if you remember Sony actually
owns the rights to Demon Souls and the
head of Sony Studios recently came out
and proclaimed his love of Demon Souls
and there's a few other accounts coming
out of e3 where PR guys hinted at the
possibility that Demon Souls 2 exists
I'm not saying this means anything but
there's been enough accounts for me to
actually mention it so but yeah I think
it would be a really clever move on Sony
spot to actually make use of the Demon
Souls I paid that they own especially
with the ps4 coming out later in the
year can you imagine if we had to sort
of separate Souls games being developed
alongside each other I think that'd be
great and I'm really trying to hold back
my excitement here I don't want to get
too hyper to something that might not
even happen anyway the PC version of
Dark Souls 2 is reportedly looking miles
better than the ps3 version which makes
a lot of sense considering the
generational gap oh and after e3 I
mentioned in my earlier video a steam
logo appeared on the Dark Souls website
right after a three please tell me we
don't have to deal with another games
for Windows Live again so thanks for
watching guys like if you liked it and
check out the other Souls news videos in
this series cheers guys and thanks for
subscribing there's a lot more content
on the way and I can't wait to show you